bine ai revenit la Înțelegerea Informației și Computației Cuantice, mă numesc John Watrous și sunt directorul tehnic pentru educație la IBM
Quantum; aceasta este lecția numărul 14 din serie și este a doua lecție a celei de-a patra unități, care este despre eroarea cuantică
corectare; în lecția anterioară am aruncat o primă privire asupra corecției erorilor cuantice, inclusiv codul Shore cu nouă qubit-uri, care stabilește că
corecția erorilor cuantice este posibilă în teorie; am discutat și despre discretizarea erorilor, care ne permite
să corectăm erori cuantice arbitrare pe qubit-uri, proiectându-le efectiv pe inversări de biți și inversări de fază
în această lecție vom discuta formalismul stabilizatorilor, care este un instrument matematic prin care putem
specifica și analiza o clasă largă de coduri cuantice de corecție a erorilor cunoscute ca coduri stabilizatoare; aceasta include codul Shore cu 9 qubit-uri
împreună cu multe alte exemple, inclusiv coduri care sunt probabil mult mai bine adaptate pentru dispozitivele cuantice reale
decât codul Shore; nu orice cod cuantic de corecție a erorilor este un cod stabilizator, dar multe sunt
inclusiv fiecare exemplu pe care îl vom vedea în această serie; există cu siguranță erori cuantice interesante și potențial utile
coduri de corecție care nu sunt coduri stabilizatoare, dar acestea tind să fie destul de mai complicate și, în orice caz, nu există
nicio îndoială că formalismul stabilizatorilor este o piatră de temelie în fundația corecției erorilor cuantice și vom
ne baza masiv pe el pentru restul unității; iată o scurtă prezentare generală a lecției: vom începe cu o scurtă discuție
despre matricele Pauli și produsele tensoriale ale matricelor Pauli, care pot reprezenta atât operații pe qubit-uri, cât și
măsurători ale qubit-urilor, după cum voi explica, și în acest context le vom numi adesea observabile; vom reveni și vom analiza
a doua oară codul de repetiție și vom vedea cum îl putem descrie prin operații și observabile Pauli, ceea ce va informa
și va conduce la o discuție generală despre codurile stabilizatoare, inclusiv câteva exemple, proprietăți de bază ale codurilor stabilizatoare
și cum putem realiza sarcinile fundamentale de codificare, detectare a erorilor și corectare a acestora
vom începe lecția cu o scurtă discuție despre operațiile Pauli, în principal pentru a pregăti terenul pentru
formalismul stabilizatorilor, dar și pentru a observa câteva fapte cheie și a stabili o terminologie de bază; în primul rând, iată matricele Pauli
inclusiv matricea identitate 2x2, precum și cele trei matrici Pauli non-identitate, pe care le vom nota prin
X, Y și Z cu majuscule în restul seriei; toate cele patru matrice sunt atât unitare, cât și hermitiene, și le putem
identifica cu operații pe un qubit, inclusiv operații pe care am putea alege să le efectuăm, precum și erori, după cum am
discutat în lecția anterioară; matricele Pauli non-identitate X, Y și Z anticomutează între ele
ceea ce înseamnă că XY este egal cu -1 * YX, XZ este egal cu minus ZX și YZ este egal
cu minus ZY, și poți verifica ușor aceste relații efectuând înmulțirile; aceste relații de anticomutare
sunt foarte simple, dar sunt extrem de importante în formalismul stabilizatorilor și în altă parte, și în mod specific
după cum vom vedea, aceste semne minus care apar când schimbăm ordinea a două matrici Pauli non-identitate diferite într-un produs corespund exact
detectării erorilor în formalismul stabilizatorilor; avem și regulile de înmulțire listate aici; fiecare
matrice Pauli este propriul său invers, ceea ce este consistent cu faptul că sunt atât unitare, cât și hermitiene, și dacă înmulțești oricare două matrice Pauli non-identitate diferite
vei obține întotdeauna plus sau minus I înmulțit cu matricea Pauli non-identitate rămasă
în particular, la un factor de fază global, Y este echivalent cu X înmulțit cu Z, ceea ce explică de ce ne concentrăm pe erorile X și Z în
corecția erorilor cuantice; X reprezintă o inversare de bit, Z reprezintă o inversare de fază și, la un factor de fază global, Y reprezintă
ambele aceste erori care apar pe același qubit; aceste patru matrice reprezintă toate
operații, erori sau absența unei erori pe un singur qubit, dar este adesea convenabil să le tensorăm împreună
pentru a efectua operații sau erori pe mai multe qubit-uri; ca punct terminologic, ori de câte ori ne referim la o operație Pauli de N qubit-uri
înțelegem un produs tensorial al oricăror n matrici Pauli, cum ar fi exemplele prezentate
aici; este de asemenea comun să folosim termenul operație Pauli atunci când există un factor de fază global, dar pentru a păstra lucrurile cât mai simple posibil
voi folosi termenul operație Pauli pentru a însemna pur și simplu un produs tensorial al matricelor Pauli; ponderea unei operații Pauli de N qubit-uri
este pur și simplu numărul de matrici Pauli non-identitate din produsul tensorial; de exemplu, produsul tensorial de N ori
al matricei identitate 2x2 cu ea însăși este o operație Pauli de pondere zero; un produs tensorial a două matrice Pauli X
și o mulțime de matrice identitate are ponderea doi și tot așa; intuitiv vorbind, ponderea unei operații Pauli de N
qubit-uri este numărul de qubit-uri pe care acționează în mod netrivial, și este tipic că codurile cuantice de corecție a erorilor sunt
concepute astfel încât să poată detecta și corecta erori reprezentate de operații Pauli până la o anumită pondere; putem
gândi la operațiile Pauli în diverse moduri, inclusiv ca operații efectuate intenționat prin gate-uri cuantice, precum și
ca erori, și vom vedea în scurt timp că operațiile Pauli pot descrie și măsurători; uneori este de asemenea util
să gândim la operațiile Pauli ca generatori ai anumitor mulțimi în sens algebric, pe care îl poți recunoaște
dacă ești familiarizat cu teoria grupurilor; dacă nu ești familiarizat cu teoria grupurilor, este în regulă, nu este cu adevărat esențial
pentru această lecție, dar dacă ești interesat să studiezi corecția erorilor cuantice în profunzime, s-ar putea să constați că unele
noțiuni de bază de teoria grupurilor sunt foarte utile; oricum, să presupunem că P1 până la PR sunt operații Pauli de N qubit-uri
deci P1 este o operație Pauli de N qubit-uri, P2 este o operație Pauli de N qubit-uri și tot așa; când ne referim la mulțimea generată de
P1 până la PR, înțelegem mulțimea tuturor matricelor pe care le putem obține înmulțind aceste matrice împreună în
orice combinație și în orice ordine dorim, luând fiecare de câte ori dorim; vom vedea câteva exemple imediat
dar mai întâi lasă-mă să menționez notația pe care o folosim pentru a denota această mulțime: mulțimea generată de P1 până la PR este
P1 până la PR separate prin virgule în interiorul parantezelor unghiulare; arată un pic ca am putea confunda cu ușurință
această notație cu notația directă, dar asta nu se întâmplă în general, și aceasta este notația tradițională în teoria
grupurilor; iată un exemplu al mulțimii generate de X, Y și Z, deci N este egal cu unu în acest exemplu deoarece nu există
produse tensoriale și luăm toate cele trei matrice Pauli non-identitate ca generatori; se dovedește că există
16 matrice care pot fi generate formând produse care includ aceste trei matrice, și poți raționa
prin regulile de înmulțire pe care le-am văzut mai devreme; în mod specific, putem obține desigur X, Y și Z, precum și identitatea
și de fapt putem obține și oricare dintre aceste patru matrice înmulțite cu I, 1 sau minus I, și asta este
WEBVTT
tot; această mulțime este cunoscută în mod obișnuit ca grupul Pauli; am putea de asemenea considera mulțimea
generată doar de X și Z și ajungem să obținem jumătate din grupul Pauli în acest caz
și un ultim exemplu, cel puțin deocamdată: putem considera mulțimea generată de X tensorial X și Z tensorial Z, deci N este egal cu
doi în acest caz și ajungem să obținem doar patru elemente de data aceasta, datorită faptului că X tensorial X și Z tensorial Z
comutează între ele; matricele Pauli și operațiile Pauli de N qubit-uri în general descriu
operații unitare, fie că sunt erori sau sunt intenționate, dar descriu și
măsurători; pentru a fi mai precis, pornind de la doar cele trei matrice Pauli non-identitate, putem asocia fiecare dintre aceste
matrice cu o măsurătoare proiectivă definită în termeni de valorile și vectorii proprii ai sale, și iată pe ecran
descompunerile spectrale ale acestor matrice care vor ajuta la clarificarea acestui aspect; în esență, când ne referim la o măsurătoare X,
o măsurătoare Y sau o măsurătoare Z, înțelegem măsurătoarea proiectivă definită prin proiecțiile
pe spațiile proprii ale acestor matrice, și de obicei gândim la valorile proprii ca fiind rezultatele corespunzătoare ale
măsurătorii; de exemplu, o măsurătoare X este o măsurătoare în raport cu baza plus-minus
a unui qubit, sau alternativ o putem descrie prin mulțimea care conține proiecțiile ket plus bra plus și ket
minus bra minus; o măsurătoare Z, pe de altă parte, nu este altceva decât o măsurătoare în baza standard
deși, după cum am spus, uneori identificăm valorile proprii cu rezultatele măsurătorii, și dacă facem asta
atunci rezultatele sunt plus unu și minus unu, spre deosebire de 0 și 1 respectiv; putem de fapt face ceva
similar pentru matrice hermitiene arbitrare, iar termenul observabil este folosit în mod obișnuit în această situație; pentru matricele Pauli
și operațiile Pauli de N qubit-uri în general, putem efectua astfel de măsurători în mod nedistructiv folosind
estimarea de fază; și pentru a mă asigura că această diagramă este clară: aici efectuăm măsurătorile în mod nedistructiv pe
qubit-ul din sus, în timp ce qubit-ul din jos este întotdeauna inițializat la starea plus, sau cu alte cuvinte Hadamard aplicat la o
stare zero, deoarece așa funcționează estimarea de fază; observă că deoarece valorile proprii
sunt doar plus unu și minus unu în acest caz, avem nevoie de un singur qubit de control, care este qubit-ul din jos în această
diagramă; mai mult de atât ar fi o risipă, deoarece există doar un bit de precizie de care trebuie să ne preocupăm; valoarea proprie
este fie plus unu, fie minus unu, și măsurătoarea este deja perfectă chiar așa; rezultatul acestei măsurători,
apropo, adică măsurătoarea în baza standard din circuit, va fi zero pentru rezultatul cu valoarea proprie plus unu
care corespunde stării plus în cazul unui observabil X, iar rezultatul este unu pentru valoarea proprie minus unu
sau starea minus în acest caz; tot ce am spus se extinde în mod natural la operațiile Pauli de N qubit-uri
cu condiția să ținem cont că atunci când gândim la un observabil, vorbim despre măsurarea valorilor proprii,
nu despre măsurarea în raport cu o bază de vectori proprii; de exemplu, consideră operația Pauli de două
qubit-uri Z tensorial Z; din nou, există două valori proprii, plus unu și minus unu, deci
măsurătoarea este descrisă prin două proiecții; observă în particular că măsurătoarea pe care o asociem cu
acest observabil nu este aceeași cu măsurarea ambelor qubit-uri cu o măsurătoare Z, sau cu alte cuvinte o măsurătoare în baza standard, ci este o măsurătoare proiectivă cu două
rezultate unde proiecțiile sunt pe spațiile întinse de toți vectorii proprii corespunzători
fiecăreia dintre cele două valori proprii, plus unu și minus unu; un alt mod de a gândi la asta este că valorile proprii ale unui produs
tensorial sunt produse ale valorilor proprii ale matricelor individuale din care luăm produsele tensoriale, și
deoarece minus 1 înmulțit cu minus 1 este același lucru ca plus 1 înmulțit cu plus 1, de exemplu, această măsurătoare nu
distinge între 0,0 și 1,1; deci dacă am măsura, să zicem, o stare Bell phi plus cu măsurătoarea
descrisă de acest observabil, am fi siguri că obținem rezultatul corespunzător valorii proprii plus unu
și starea ar rămâne neschimbată, spre deosebire de a colapsa la 0,0 sau 1,1, ceea ce s-ar întâmpla dacă
am efectua măsurătorile în baza standard pe cele două qubit-uri; deci o măsurătoare Z tensorial Z nu este
același lucru cu efectuarea a două măsurători Z independent, dar putem de fapt efectua astfel de măsurători folosind estimarea de
fază exact în același mod ca înainte, folosind un singur qubit de control, după cum se arată în diagrama de circuit care
se generalizează la orice operație Pauli de N qubit-uri în locul lui Z tensorial Z; când avem doar matrice Pauli Z,
apropo, putem simplifica circuit-ul astfel, și ceea ce acesta dezvăluie, care este de asemenea evident din proiecțiile care definesc
măsurătoarea, este că efectuarea unei măsurători Z tensorial Z pe două qubit-uri este echivalentă cu măsurarea parității lor
gândind în termeni de baza standard, și aceasta se generalizează la produsul tensorial al oricărui număr de matrice
Pauli Z; în continuare vom arunca o a doua privire asupra codului de repetiție pe trei biți, de data aceasta formulând-o în termeni de operații Pauli
acesta va fi primul nostru exemplu, destul de simplu, al unui cod stabilizator, și vom discuta cum să generalizăm această
noțiune în scurt timp, dar este util să vedem cum funcționează în acest caz simplu mai întâi; reamintește că atunci când aplicăm
codul de repetiție pe 3 biți la qubit-uri, codificăm o stare qubit dată, Alpha 0 plus beta 1, ca Alpha 000 plus beta 111
și vom numi această codificare de trei qubit-uri Psi pentru comoditate; deci prin definiție, Psi este o codificare validă de trei qubit-uri
a unei stări qubit, dar dacă vrem să verificăm asta este suficient să verificăm că următoarele două ecuații sunt adevărate; prima
ecuație afirmă că aplicarea operațiilor Z la cele mai din stânga două qubit-uri ale lui Psi nu face nimic lui Psi, ceea ce înseamnă că
Psi este un vector propriu al lui Z tensorial Z tensorial Identitate, sau pur și simplu ZZ identitate pe scurt, cu valoarea proprie unu; a doua
ecuație este similară, cu excepția că operațiile Z sunt aplicate celor mai din dreapta două qubit-uri; ideea este că dacă gândim la Psi
ca la o combinație liniară de stări de bază standard, atunci prima ecuație implică că putem avea coeficienți nenuli doar pentru stările de bază standard
unde cei mai din stânga doi biți au paritate pară, sau echivalent sunt egali, iar a doua ecuație implică că putem
avea coeficienți nenuli doar pentru stările de bază standard pentru care cei mai din dreapta doi biți au paritate pară; un alt mod de a gândi la asta
este să privim aceste două operații Pauli ca observabile, și dacă am măsura aceste două observabile folosind
circuit-ul simplificat pe care l-am menționat cu puțin înainte, atunci am fi siguri că obținem un rezultat al măsurătorii corespunzător valorilor proprii plus unu
deoarece Psi este un vector propriu al ambelor observabile cu valoarea proprie unu; dar această versiune simplificată a circuit-ului combinat
WEBVTT
pentru măsurarea independentă a observabilelor nu este altceva decât circuit-ul nostru de verificare a parității pentru codul de repetiție pe 3 biți
și astfel vedem că cele două ecuații ale noastre împreună sunt echivalente cu faptul că circuit-ul de verificare a parității produce 0,0
care este sindromul ce indică că nu au fost detectate erori; operațiile Pauli de trei qubit-uri
ZZ identitate și identitate ZZ sunt numite generatori stabilizatori pentru acest cod, iar stabilizatorul codului este mulțimea
generată de generatorii stabilizatori; această mulțime, stabilizatorul, este un obiect matematic fundamental important
asociat cu acest cod, și vom discuta în continuare rolul pe care îl joacă pe măsură ce lecția continuă; deocamdată
voi menționa doar că am fi putut face o alegere diferită pentru generatori; de exemplu, am fi putut selecta Z identitate Z în locul oricăruia
dintre generatorii pe care i-am selectat, și codul și stabilizatorul ar fi exact aceleași; în continuare vom considera detectarea inversărilor de biți
pentru codul de repetiție pe trei biți, cu accent pe interacțiunile și relațiile dintre operațiile Pauli
implicate, și anume generatorii stabilizatori și erorile în sine; să presupunem că am codificat un
qubit folosind codul de repetiție pe trei biți și apare o eroare de inversare a bitului pe qubit-ul cel mai din stânga; aceasta determină ca starea noastră Psi să fie
transformată conform acțiunii unei operații X sau erori X pe qubit-ul cel mai din stânga; după cum știm deja, putem detecta
această eroare efectuând verificările de paritate pentru codul de repetiție pe trei biți, sau echivalent putem măsura
codificarea în mod nedistructiv, tratând generatorii stabilizatori ca observabile; să începem cu primul
generator stabilizator și să vedem ce se întâmplă; starea noastră a fost afectată de o eroare X și dorim să înțelegem
cum este influențată măsurarea generatorului stabilizator ca observabil de această eroare; X și Z anticomutează, în timp ce
totul comutează cu matricea identitate, deci rezultă că ZZ identitate anticomutează cu X identitate
identitate; deci obținem un semn minus când ordinea este schimbată, și știm de asemenea că ZZ identitate nu face nimic lui Psi
deoarece Psi este o codificare validă a unui qubit, iar codificările valide sunt întotdeauna vectori proprii cu valoarea proprie plus unu ai ambilor generatori stabilizatori
ceea ce ne lasă cu minus X identitate identitate aplicat lui Psi, și prin urmare X identitate identitate aplicat la
Psi este un vector propriu al lui ZZ identitate cu valoarea proprie minus unu; putem de asemenea face ceva similar
cu al doilea generator stabilizator, dar de data aceasta eroarea comutează cu generatorul stabilizator, deci starea noastră
coruptă este din nou un vector propriu al generatorului stabilizator, dar de data aceasta valoarea proprie este pozitivă
unu; deci starea noastră coruptă este un vector propriu al ambilor generatori stabilizatori, iar valoarea proprie este plus unu sau
minus unu în funcție de dacă eroarea comutează sau anticomutează cu fiecare generator stabilizator; pentru primul
eroarea și generatorul stabilizator anticomutează, iar pentru al doilea comutează; și va fi întotdeauna una sau alta, deoarece oricare două
operații Pauli fie comutează, fie anticomutează; între timp, starea actuală Psi nu joacă un rol important
aici, cu excepția faptului că generatorii stabilizatori acționează trivial pe această stare; deci când ne gândim la
detectarea erorilor, nu trebuie să ne preocupăm de starea specifică codificată; tot ce contează este dacă eroarea comutează sau
anticomutează cu fiecare generator stabilizator; deci hai să facem un tabel cu câte un rând pentru fiecare generator stabilizator
și câte o coloană pentru fiecare eroare; iată că am inclus doar erorile corespunzătoare unei singure inversări de bit, precum și
nicio eroare, indicată prin identitate tensoriată cu ea însăși de trei ori; am putea adăuga mai multe coloane pentru alte erori dacă am vrea
dar deocamdată ne vom concentra doar pe aceste erori; intrarea în tabel este fie plus unu, fie minus unu în funcție de
dacă eroarea și generatorul stabilizator comutează sau anticomutează; deci pentru fiecare eroare din tabel putem privi
coloana corespunzătoare pentru a vedea cum va transforma acea eroare orice codificare dată într-un vector propriu cu valoarea proprie plus unu sau minus unu
al fiecărui generator stabilizator; aceste coloane corespund exact sindromului pe care l-am obține din
verificările de paritate, care sunt echivalente cu măsurătorile nedistructive ale generatorilor stabilizatori ca
observabile; desigur, intrările din acest tabel sunt plus unu și minus unu, nu zero și unu respectiv
și dacă preferi, poți gândi la sindroame ca la șiruri binare corespunzătoare, nu ca la coloane de plus unu și minus unu, dar există o
corespondență directă; și pentru a face conexiunea dintre sindroame și valorile proprii mai clară și directă,
voi numi acești vectori de plus unu și minus unu sindroame, ca înainte; sindroamele ne spun
ceva despre orice eroare a avut loc, și în special dacă știm că una dintre aceste patru posibile erori
a apărut, sindromul ne indică care a fost, și o putem corecta aplicând din nou eroarea, dacă
alegem; în continuare voi spune doar câteva lucruri despre sindroame și în particular vom arunca o privire mai atentă la
aspectele lor algebrice; codificările noastre sunt stări de trei qubit-uri, deci sunt vectori unitari într-un
spațiu vectorial complex de opt dimensiuni, iar ceea ce fac cele patru sindroame posibile este să împartă acest spațiu de opt dimensiuni
în patru subspatii bidimensionale, ceea ce înseamnă că vectorii din oricare dintre aceste subspatii ne vor da întotdeauna același
sindrom; în mai multe detalii, această diagramă ilustrează cum este împărțit spațiul de opt dimensiuni
fiecare generator stabilizator împarte spațiul în două subspatii de dimensiune egală, și anume spațiul vectorilor proprii cu valoarea proprie plus unu
și spațiul vectorilor proprii cu valoarea proprie minus unu; de exemplu, vectorii proprii cu valoarea proprie plus unu ai lui ZZ identitate sunt combinații liniare
ale stărilor de bază standard pentru care cei mai din stânga doi biți au paritate pară, iar vectorii proprii cu valoarea proprie minus unu sunt combinații liniare
ale stărilor de bază standard pentru care cei mai din stânga doi biți au paritate impară; situația este similară pentru
celălalt generator stabilizator, cu excepția că sunt cei mai din dreapta doi biți, nu cei mai din stânga; deci aceste patru subspatii sunt ușor de
descris în acest caz datorită faptului că acesta este un cod foarte simplu; în particular, subspațiul
corespunzând sindromului plus unu, plus unu este spațiul întins de ket 000 și ket 111, care este spațiul de
codificări valide și acesta se numește spațiul codului; în general, spațiile sunt întinse de stările de bază standard
prezentate în pătratele corespunzătoare, deși nu este neapărat la fel de clar sau ușor de văzut; sindroamele
partiționează de asemenea toate operațiile Pauli de trei qubit-uri, care reprezintă posibilele erori Pauli ce ar putea apărea, în patru colecții egale
în funcție de sindromul pe care l-ar cauza acea eroare; de exemplu, orice operație Pauli
care comutează cu ambii generatori stabilizatori rezultă în sindromul plus unu, plus unu; și dintre cele 64 de posibile trei
qubit operații Pauli, există exact 16 în această categorie, inclusiv cele trei menționate pe ecran, și la fel pentru celelalte trei
WEBVTT
sindroame; nu este evident, dar este adevărat; și această proprietate de bază că sindroamele partiționează atât spațiul de stări
în care trăiesc codificările, cât și toate posibilele operații Pauli din spațiu, în bucăți de dimensiuni egale, este ceva ce
este adevărat în general pentru codurile stabilizatoare, pe care le vom defini cu precizie în curând; deși este mai mult o paranteză la
acest punct, merită menționat că operațiile Pauli care comutează cu ambii generatori stabilizatori, sau echivalent
operațiile Pauli care rezultă în sindromul plus unu, plus unu, dar nu sunt ele însele proporționale cu elemente ale stabilizatorului se dovedesc a se comporta la fel ca
operațiile Pauli pe un singur qubit pe qubit-ul logic pe care l-am codificat; de exemplu, XXX comutează cu
ambii generatori stabilizatori, dar nu este proporțional cu niciun element al stabilizatorului, și într-adevăr este clar dacă
te gândești la acest cod pentru un moment că efectul pe care îl are această operație asupra unei codificări este echivalent cu un gate X pe
qubit-ul logic care a fost codificat; și din nou, aceasta este ceva ce se generalizează la toate codurile stabilizatoare; acum este momentul să definim codurile stabilizatoare
în general, și modul în care funcționează este că facem ceva complet analog cu ceea ce am discutat pentru
codul de repetiție pe trei biți, cu excepția că alegem diferiți generatori stabilizatori, pe care îi vom numi P1
până la PR pentru scopul acestei explicații; acești generatori stabilizatori trebuie să fie toți operații Pauli de N qubit-uri
unde N este numărul de qubit-uri folosite pentru codificare, și nu putem alege pur și simplu orice set de generatori stabilizatori; ei
trebuie să satisfacă câteva condiții de bază; în primul rând, generatorii stabilizatori trebuie să comuteze TOȚI între
ei; în cazul codului de repetiție pe trei biți, nu am luat notă de asta, dar este simplu de observat că ZZ identitate și identitate
ZZ comutează de fapt, deoarece Z comutează cu sine și totul comutează cu
identitatea; pentru codurile stabilizatoare cu generatori stabilizatori mai complicați, pe de altă parte, inclusiv coduri unde avem
atât X-uri, cât și Z-uri care apar în generatorii stabilizatori, aceasta este o condiție importantă care trebuie
verificată; un mod de a gândi la necesitatea acestei condiții este că vom trata generatorii stabilizatori ca observabile, și prin cererea că
toți comutează, ne asigurăm că ordinea în care efectuăm aceste măsurători nu
contează; în al doilea rând, generatorii stabilizatori trebuie să formeze un așa-numit set minimal de generare, ceea ce înseamnă că dacă am elimina oricăruia
dintre ei am obține un stabilizator mai mic; un mod de a exprima aceasta matematic este arătat aici pe
ecran; strict vorbind, această condiție nu este cu adevărat esențială pentru modul în care funcționează un cod stabilizator în sens operațional
și uneori are sens să gândim la seturi de generare non-minimale, după cum vom vedea în lecția următoare; dar
pentru scopul analizării codurilor stabilizatoare și explicării proprietăților lor, vom presupune că această condiție este
îndeplinită; practic, această condiție garantează că fiecare observabil pe care îl măsurăm pentru a obține sindromul adaugă
informații despre posibilele erori, spre deosebire de a fi redundant și de a da rezultate care ar putea fi ușor deduse din ceilalți generatori stabilizatori ca
observabile; și în final, trebuie să fie cazul că cel puțin un vector nenul este fixat de toți
generatorii stabilizatori, și aceasta se dovedește a fi echivalentă cu cererea că minus 1 înmulțit cu identitatea pe N qubit-uri nu este
conținut în stabilizator; nu este evident, dar ideea este că este posibil să alegi un set minimal de generare
al operațiilor Pauli de N qubit-uri care comutează toate între ele și totuși niciun vector nu este simultan un vector propriu cu valoarea proprie plus unu
al tuturor lor, și nu vrem să ne preocupăm de această posibilitate, deoarece codurile unde nu există codificări valide nu sunt
interesante; deci acestea sunt cerințele pentru generatorii stabilizatori ai unui cod stabilizator, și dacă avem un set de generatori care
satisface aceste condiții, atunci avem un cod stabilizator valid și putem considera proprietățile sale; există multe
coduri stabilizatoare diferite cu diverse proprietăți care le fac interesante sau nu, dar toate satisfac anumite proprietăți de bază
care amintesc de cele pe care le-am observat deja pentru codul de repetiție pe trei biți
vom analiza câteva exemple în scurt timp, dar înainte de asta lasă-mă să menționez că atunci când ne referim la spațiul codului unui cod stabilizator, înțelegem subspațiul
spațiului de stări de N qubit-uri care include fiecare vector care este simultan un vector propriu cu valoarea proprie plus unu al fiecăruia dintre
generatorii stabilizatori; acesta este subspațiul spațiului de stări de N qubit-uri în care trăiesc codificările valide, și vom mai spune
despre acest subspațiu pe măsură ce lecția continuă; acum hai să aruncăm o privire la câteva exemple de coduri stabilizatoare
iată exemplul pe care l-am discutat deja: codul obișnuit de repetiție pe 3 biți, și putem de asemenea exprima
versiunea modificată a acelui cod din lecția anterioară, care poate detecta o inversare de fază în loc de o inversare de bit, ca un cod stabilizator, după cum se arată
de data aceasta generatorii stabilizatori măsoară observabile XX, nu ZZ, deci acestea sunt practic
verificări de paritate în baza plus-minus, nu în baza standard; în ambele cazuri putem
vedea imediat că avem un cod stabilizator valid, deoarece generatorii stabilizatori comutează; acestea sunt seturi minimale de
generare și spațiul codului este netrivial, după cum știm deja; dar putem vedea și destul de clar că
nu putem genera minus 1 înmulțit cu identitatea; și iată codul Shore cu 9 qubit-uri, care este de asemenea un cod stabilizator
exprimat prin generatori stabilizatori; în acest caz avem practic trei copii ale codului de repetiție pe trei
biți, una pentru fiecare dintre cele trei blocuri de trei qubit-uri, precum și ultimii doi generatori stabilizatori care
iau o formă care amintește de circuit-ul pe care l-am văzut în lecția anterioară pentru detectarea inversărilor de fază pentru acest
cod; un alt mod de a gândi la acești ultimi doi generatori stabilizatori este că iau exact aceeași formă ca
avem pentru codul de repetiție pe trei biți pentru inversări de fază, cu excepția că substituim XXX pentru X, iar motivul pentru
asta este că XXX corespunde unei operații X pe qubit-ul logic codificat folosind codul de repetiție pe 3 biți; dar
aceasta este o paranteză și nu este ceva de care să ne facem griji acum; în caz că nu este clar, urmează să aruncăm o privire la câteva
exemple în plus, dar înainte de asta lasă-mă să menționez că oamenii omit adesea simbolurile produsului tensorial când descriu codurile stabilizatoare, deoarece tinde să
le facă mai ușor de citit; deci iată cum arată aceste coduri fără simbolurile produsului tensorial
dar desigur, acestea sunt produse tensoriale și nu produse de matrice obișnuite; de exemplu, pur și simplu omitem simbolurile produsului tensorial astfel încât să fie mai puțin
aglomerat și tiparele să fie mai clare; iată un alt exemplu: se numește
codul Steane cu 7 qubit-uri și are câteva caracteristici destul de remarcabile; ne vom întoarce la acesta
din când în când de-a lungul lecțiilor rămase ale unității, dar deocamdată putem pur și simplu verifica că este un cod stabilizator valid
în particular, primii trei generatori stabilizatori comutează clar între ei, deoarece Z comutează cu
WEBVTT
sine și identitatea comutează cu tot, și situația este similară pentru ultimii trei; deci rămâne de
verificat că dacă luăm unul dintre generatorii stabilizatori Z și unul dintre generatorii stabilizatori X, atunci aceștia comutează
și este suficient de ușor să parcurgem cele nouă posibile perechi pentru a verifica că în toate aceste cazuri vom
avea întotdeauna un X și un Z care se potrivesc în aceeași poziție de un număr par de ori; deci cei doi generatori vor comuta la fel
cum XX și ZZ comutează; este un set minimal de generare și are un spațiu de cod netrivial, dar
nu voi încerca să argumentez asta în acest video; în schimb voi lăsa asta pentru tine să te gândești dacă dorești; codul Steane cu 7 qubit-uri este similar
cu codul Shore cu 9 qubit-uri în sensul că codifică un singur qubit și permite corectarea unei erori arbitrare pe un qubit, dar necesită doar
șapte qubit-uri în loc de nouă; acesta nu este cel mai mic număr de qubit-uri necesar pentru ca un cod de corecție a erorilor să
codifice un qubit și să corecteze o eroare arbitrară pe un singur qubit; iată un cod stabilizator care este
de obicei numit pur și simplu codul cu 5 qubit-uri, care de asemenea codifică un singur qubit și poate corecta orice eroare pe un singur qubit
și cinci este cel mai mic număr de qubit-uri pentru care acest lucru este posibil; iată un alt exemplu de
cod stabilizator, deși nu este cu adevărat un cod ca atare, în sensul că spațiul codului este
unidimensional; în particular, spațiul codului pentru acest cod este spațiul întins de un ebit, sau cu alte cuvinte o stare
Bell phi plus; deci nu poți codifica efectiv qubit-uri folosind acest cod, dar este totuși un cod stabilizator valid unde spațiul
codului se întâmplă să fie unidimensional; și este posibil să faci ceva similar pentru o stare GHz
deci acestea sunt câteva exemple de coduri stabilizatoare și vom vedea infinit mai multe exemple în
lecția următoare; să presupunem că ni s-a dat un cod stabilizator; o întrebare firească de pus despre el
poate chiar prima întrebare care ne vine în minte este: câte qubit-uri codifică acesta? Acea întrebare are un răspuns foarte simplu
și pentru a-l explica, hai să fim precisi cu privire la codul stabilizator luat în considerare; avem R generatori stabilizatori de N qubit-uri
P1 până la PR care satisfac cele trei cerințe pe care le-am menționat mai devreme, și anume că
generatorii stabilizatori comutează toți între ei, acesta este un set minimal de generare, deci nu am obține același
stabilizator dacă am elimina unul dintre generatori, și există cel puțin un vector nenul în spațiul
codului; după cum indică teorema prezentată pe ecran, trebuie atunci să fie că spațiul codului al codului stabilizator are
dimensiunea 2 la puterea N minus R, sau alt mod de a spune aceasta este că putem codifica N
minus R qubit-uri folosind acest cod; deci intuitiv vorbind, avem N qubit-uri în codificările noastre și fiecare
generator stabilizator ia efectiv un qubit în termeni de câte qubit-uri putem codifica
această teoremă nu este prea greu de demonstrat și îți voi arăta o demonstrație într-un moment, dar mai întâi vom arunca o privire la câteva
exemple; pornind de la codul obișnuit de repetiție pe 3 biți, avem trei qubit-uri în codificările noastre
deci N este egal cu trei și există R egal cu 2 generatori stabilizatori, deci putem codifica un
qubit folosind acest cod; observă că aceasta nu este despre care sau câte erori pot fi detectate sau
corectate; aceasta este o altă problemă; aceasta este doar o afirmație despre dimensiunea spațiului
codului; pentru un alt exemplu, consideră codul cu 5 qubit-uri; aici avem cinci qubit-uri și patru
generatori stabilizatori, deci din nou spațiul codului are dimensiunea doi, ceea ce înseamnă că putem codifica un qubit folosind acest
cod; și un exemplu în plus deocamdată: pentru codul stabilizator ebit, avem două qubit-uri și doi generatori stabilizatori, deci
spațiul codului este unidimensional și, după cum am menționat mai devreme, este spațiul întins de starea Bell phi plus
vom vedea mai multe exemple pe măsură ce continuăm, inclusiv coduri unde putem codifica mai mult de un qubit, dar deocamdată
să vedem cum putem demonstra teorema; primul lucru pe care trebuie să-l observăm este că deoarece generatorii stabilizatori
comutează și formează un set minimal de generare, și deoarece fiecare operație Pauli este propriul său invers, fiecare
element din stabilizator poate fi exprimat în mod unic ca un produs unde ridicăm fiecare generator stabilizator
PK la puterea AK, unde fiecare AK este fie zero, fie unu, și apoi înmulțim rezultatele
împreună; un alt mod de a spune aceasta este că obținem fiecare element al stabilizatorului înmulțind împreună un subset al
generatorilor stabilizatori și nu obținem niciodată același element stabilizator din subset-uri diferite; și un lucru pe care
aceasta îl implică este că singurul mod de a exprima operația identitate de N qubit-uri în acest mod este să luăm toate puterile la valoarea
zero; în continuare, să definim pi K ca proiecția pe spațiul propriu cu valoarea proprie plus unu al lui PK, pentru fiecare K de la 1 la R, și există
o formulă simplă pentru această proiecție: putem pur și simplu face media lui PK cu identitatea pe N qubit-uri, ceea ce lasă efectiv valorile proprii
plus unu singure și deplasează toate valorile proprii minus unu la zero; acum spațiul codului este definit ca mulțimea tuturor vectorilor care sunt simultan vectori proprii cu valoarea proprie plus unu ai tuturor
generatorilor stabilizatori; dat că generatorii stabilizatori comutează, proiecțiile trebuie de asemenea să comuteze, și asta
implică că produsul acestor proiecții este și el o proiecție, și în particular este proiecția pe
intersecția subspațiilor pe care proiecțiile individuale le proiectează, sau cu alte cuvinte este proiecția pe
spațiul codului; putem extinde acest produs și ceea ce obținem este media peste fiecare
element al stabilizatorului; și în final, deoarece dimensiunea oricărui subspațiu este egală cu
urma proiecției pe acel subspațiu, găsim că dimensiunea spațiului codului este media urmelor peste elementele
stabilizatorului; dar cu excepția operației identitate de N qubit-uri, toate elementele stabilizatorului trebuie să aibă
urmă egală cu zero, deoarece cele trei matrice Pauli non-identitate au toate urma egală cu zero; urma operației identitate de N qubit-uri
este 2 la puterea N, deci găsim că dimensiunea spațiului codului este 2 la puterea N minus R, ceea ce demonstrează
teorema; în continuare voi spune doar câteva lucruri despre cum pot fi codificate qubit-urile folosind coduri stabilizatoare, dar pentru a face asta mai întâi
trebuie să introducem operațiile Clifford; operațiile Clifford sunt operații unitare pe orice număr de
qubit-uri care pot fi implementate prin circuit-uri cuantice cu un set restricționat de gate-uri, și anume gate-uri Hadamard, gate-uri S
și gate-uri CNOT; observă că gate-urile T nu sunt incluse, nici gate-urile Toffoli sau gate-urile Fredkin
și nu numai că acele gate-uri nu sunt incluse în această listă, dar de fapt nu este posibil să implementezi acele gate-uri
folosind cele listate aici; deci nu sunt operații Clifford; pe de altă parte, operațiile Pauli
WEBVTT
sunt operații Clifford și în mod specific pot fi implementate folosind secvențe de gate-uri Hadamard și S
deci acesta este un mod simplu de a defini operațiile Clifford, dar nu explică cu adevărat de ce sunt definite în
acest mod sau ce este special la această colecție particulară de gate-uri; iată motivul real pentru care operațiile Clifford sunt definite astfel
la un factor de fază global, operațiile Clifford de N qubit-uri sunt exact operațiile unitare
care transformă întotdeauna operațiile Pauli în operații Pauli prin conjugare; pentru a fi mai precis, o operație unitară de N qubit-uri
U este o operație Clifford la un factor de fază global dacă și numai dacă pentru fiecare operație Pauli de N qubit-uri
conjugând acea operație Pauli prin U ne dă plus sau minus unu înmulțit cu o altă operație Pauli de N qubit-uri, posibil diferită
poți verifica ușor că această proprietate este adevărată pentru gate-urile Hadamard, gate-urile S
și gate-urile CNOT; deci se aplică în mod necesar pentru circuit-uri construite din aceste gate-uri; ce este mai greu de demonstrat este că merge
și în cealaltă direcție, adică dacă ni se dă o anumită operație unitară de N qubit-uri U care satisface această
proprietate, atunci trebuie să fie posibil să o implementăm la un factor de fază global folosind doar gate-uri Hadamard, S și CNOT
nu voi parcurge demonstrația acestei implicații, dar este adevărată și o poți căuta dacă ești
interesat; operațiile Clifford nu sunt universale pentru computația cuantică, ceea ce înseamnă că nu putem rula computații cuantice arbitrare
folosind doar gate-uri Hadamard, S și CNOT; de fapt, pentru o valoare dată a lui N, există doar un număr finit de
operații Clifford de N qubit-uri, deci este un set discret de operații; deci spre deosebire de
un set universal de gate-uri cuantice, nu putem aproxima operații unitare arbitrare la orice nivel dorit de precizie; și
de fapt, efectuarea operațiilor Clifford pe stări de bază standard urmată de măsurători în baza standard nu ne poate permite
să efectuăm computații care sunt în afara razei de acțiune a algoritmilor clasici, deoarece putem simula eficient computații de această formă
în mod clasic; acest fapt este cunoscut ca teorema Gottesman-Knill, iar demonstrația standard a acelei teoreme este în anumit sens
bazată pe formalismul stabilizatorilor; în particular, modul în care funcționează este că putem urmări modul în care operațiile Clifford transformă operațiile Pauli
prin conjugare, ceea ce poate fi făcut eficient, și apoi deducem din asta ce fac computațiile cu
qubit-urile; deci ce legătură are asta cu codurile stabilizatoare? Ei bine, un cod stabilizator ne oferă
un spațiu de cod de o anumită dimensiune și avem libertatea de a folosi acel spațiu de cod cum dorim; deci nimic nu ne obligă să codificăm
qubit-urile în acel spațiu într-un mod specific, dar va fi întotdeauna posibil să efectuăm o codificare folosind o operație Clifford
ca encoder; asta este frumos deoarece operațiile Clifford sunt relativ simple comparativ cu operațiile unitare arbitrare
există moduri de a le optimiza implementarea, care funcționează pe linii similare cu demonstrația teoremei Gottesman-Knill,
și ca rezultat, circuit-urile pentru implementarea lor nu trebuie niciodată să fie prea
mari; în particular, putem efectua întotdeauna o codificare folosind o operație Clifford care necesită puțin mai puțin decât un număr pătratic de gate-uri
deoarece aceasta este de fapt adevărată pentru orice operație Clifford; deci concluzia este că pentru un cod stabilizator dat, este întotdeauna
posibil să codifici qubit-urile eficient folosind acel cod, iar instrumentele matematice utile pentru înțelegerea operațiilor Clifford pot ajuta cu acest
proces; de exemplu, iată un encoder pentru codul Steane cu 7 qubit-uri; este o operație Clifford și, cum se dovedește,
acesta nu necesită nici măcar gate-uri S; pentru codurile stabilizatoare generale, detectarea erorilor funcționează în felul următor:
ca înainte, vom presupune că avem generatori stabilizatori de N qubit-uri P1 până la PR și vom lăsa E să fie o operație Pauli de N qubit-uri
reprezentând o eroare ipotetică pe o codificare; considerăm doar operațiile Pauli ca erori,
apropo, deoarece discretizarea erorilor funcționează în același mod pentru codurile stabilizatoare arbitrare ca și pentru codul Shore cu 9 qubit-uri
modul în care verificăm erorile este să măsurăm fiecare dintre generatorii stabilizatori ca
observabile; există R generatori stabilizatori, deci aceasta înseamnă R rezultate, fiecare fiind plus unu sau minus unu,
sau o valoare binară dacă preferi să asociezi zero cu plus unu și unu cu minus unu; și aceste R rezultate
formează împreună sindromul, la fel ca am avut pentru codul de repetiție pe trei biți când R era egal cu
doi; în general, există trei cazuri posibile pentru eroarea E în termeni de detectarea sa, și ele sunt după cum urmează: în primul rând,
ar putea fi că E este în stabilizator, adică este posibil să generezi E din generatorii stabilizatori, sau
ușor mai general, ar putea fi că E este echivalent cu un element al stabilizatorului la un factor de fază
global; în acest caz, E nu este cu adevărat o eroare, deoarece nu are niciun efect în spațiul codului, altul decât să injecteze posibil
un factor de fază global, care nu are niciun efect; deci nu trebuie să ne preocupăm deloc de astfel de erori; orice
acțiune netrivială ar putea avea loc în afara spațiului codului, deci nu ne privește
mult mai îngrijorătoare este posibilitatea că E nu este în stabilizator chiar și la un factor de fază global, dar
totuși comutează cu fiecare dintre generatorii noștri stabilizatori; reamintește că este
anticomutarea erorii cu un generator stabilizator care determină apariția unui minus unu undeva în sindrom
dar asta nu se întâmplă în acest caz; deci aceasta este o eroare care schimbă efectiv vectorii din spațiul codului în vreun mod
netrivial, și știm asta deoarece altfel ar fi proporțională cu un element al stabilizatorului, dar este
nedetectată de cod; deci acesta este cazul rău: avem o eroare care potențial schimbă
orice informație cuantică am codificat, dar codul este inconștient de acest fapt; de exemplu, pentru codul de repetiție pe trei biți,
XXX se încadrează în această categorie; și ultima posibilitate este că E
anticomutează cu cel puțin unul dintre generatorii stabilizatori, ceea ce înseamnă că codul detectează această eroare deoarece
vom obține un sindrom cu cel puțin un minus unu undeva, ceea ce indică că ceva este în neregulă și va trebui să încercăm să corectăm această eroare
cumva; deci acestea sunt posibilitățile; ca punct terminologic,
când ne referim la distanța unui cod stabilizator, înțelegem ponderea minimă a unei operații Pauli care se încadrează
în a doua categorie, adică schimbă spațiul codului în vreun mod netrivial, dar codul nu
detectează asta; și când spunem că un cod stabilizator este un cod stabilizator N,M,D
folosind paranteze drepte duble, după cum se arată pe ecran, ceea ce înseamnă este că codificările sunt de lungime N qubit-uri, și
codul este capabil să codifice M qubit-uri, deci spațiul codului are dimensiunea 2 la puterea M, iar distanța sa este D; deci o eroare trebuie să
WEBVTT
aibă pondere D sau mai mare pentru a schimba starea logică a oricărui qubit codificat fără a fi detectată ca
eroare; acum vom arunca o privire la codul Steane cu 7 qubit-uri ca exemplu și vom determina care este distanța sa
iată generatorii stabilizatori pentru acest cod, și reamintește că distanța este ponderea minimă a unei operații Pauli de N qubit-uri
care comutează cu toți generatorii stabilizatori, dar nu este ea însăși în stabilizator, nici
nu este proporțională cu un element al stabilizatorului; ceea ce vom determina este că acest cod are distanța
trei; modul în care vom determina asta este să considerăm mai întâi orice operație Pauli cu pondere cel mult doi și vom
concluziona că singurul mod în care aceasta poate comuta cu toți cei șase generatori stabilizatori este să fie identitatea, care este întotdeauna un element al
stabilizatorului; deci să presupunem că matricele Pauli posibil non-identitate care formează această operație, pe care le vom
numi P și Q, apar în cele mai din stânga două poziții; acesta este doar un caz și trebuie de fapt să
considerăm toate celelalte locații posibile pentru aceste matrice Pauli posibil non-identitate, dar argumentul este practic același pentru toate
locațiile posibile; ei bine, prin ipoteză, această operație comutează cu toți cei șase
generatori stabilizatori; deci în particular comutează cu acesta și comutează și cu acesta
Q se aliniază cu matricea identitate în ambii acești generatori, motiv pentru care i-am ales pe aceștia doi, și avem matrice
identitate în cele mai din dreapta cinci poziții ale acestei erori; deci concluzionăm că P trebuie să comute cu ambele X
și Z, deoarece altfel această eroare ar anticomuta cu unul dintre acești doi generatori; dar singura matrice Pauli care
comutează cu ambele X și Z este identitatea; deci P trebuie să fie identitatea, și acum că știm asta, putem
alege doi generatori stabilizatori în plus care au un X și un Z în a doua poziție de la stânga și putem
trage o concluzie similară cu privire la Q; deci nu există nicio modalitate ca o eroare cu pondere cel mult 2 să treacă nedetectată de acest cod
dacă nu este doar operația identitate, care se află în stabilizator; deci aceasta nu este de fapt o
eroare; pe de altă parte, există operații Pauli de pondere trei care comutează cu toți cei șase generatori stabilizatori
dar nu sunt proporționale cu elemente ale stabilizatorului, și iată două exemple; deci am concluzionat că acest
cod are distanța trei; ultimul lucru pe care îl vom discuta în această lecție este corectarea erorilor pentru
codurile stabilizatoare; ca de obicei, vom presupune că codul nostru este specificat prin generatori stabilizatori de N qubit-uri
P1 până la PR, și să începem să gândim puțin la toate posibilele erori care ar putea apărea
există 2 la puterea R sindroame posibile și, după cum am menționat mai devreme în lecție, aceste sindroame partiționează toate
posibilele operații Pauli de N qubit-uri în colecții de dimensiuni egale; deci aceasta înseamnă 4 la puterea N împărțit la 2 la puterea R operații Pauli
în fiecare set; deci când vedem un sindrom particular, ar putea fi că oricare dintre aceste 4 la puterea N împărțit la 2
la puterea R erori este responsabilă; supraestimăm un pic totuși, deoarece unele dintre aceste
erori au exact același efect în spațiul codului; în particular, dacă avem o eroare E și o înmulțim pe E cu orice
element al stabilizatorului S, atunci vom obține o altă eroare care are exact același efect în spațiul codului ca E; deci
acestea sunt erori echivalente; stabilizatorul are 2 la puterea R elemente, și dacă ținem cont de asta, atunci găsim
că pentru fiecare sindrom există 4 la puterea N minus R clase de echivalență de erori care ar fi putut cauza acel
sindrom; și ceea ce înseamnă asta este că dacă R nu este egal cu N, caz în care avem un spațiu de cod unidimensional și
prin urmare nu putem codifica deloc qubit-uri, nu va fi posibil să corectăm orice eroare pe care o putem detecta; în schimb,
ce trebuie să facem este să alegem o singură operație de corecție pentru fiecare sindrom în speranța de a corecta doar o clasă de erori echivalente
deci cum ar trebui să alegem ce corecție să efectuăm pentru fiecare sindrom? O strategie naturală este să alegem
operația Pauli cu ponderea cea mai mică care cauzează sindromul pe care îl măsurăm, cu ideea că operațiile Pauli cu pondere mai mică
reprezintă explicații mai probabile pentru acel sindrom; s-ar putea ca asta să nu fie de fapt
cazul pentru unele modele de zgomot, iar o altă strategie naturală este să calculăm cumva eroarea cea mai probabilă care cauzează
sindromul dat; dar deocamdată vom considera doar strategia unde încercăm să corectăm erorile selectând operația Pauli cu ponderea cea mai mică care cauzează
sindromul; pentru un cod stabilizator cu distanța D, această strategie ne va permite întotdeauna să corectăm erori cu pondere strict
mai mică decât jumătate din D, sau cu alte cuvinte pondere cel mult D minus 1 împărțit la 2, și voi explica pe scurt de ce este
asta; aceasta va arăta, de exemplu, că codul Steane cu 7 qubit-uri poate corecta orice eroare Pauli cu pondere unu, și prin
discretizarea erorilor aceasta înseamnă că, la fel ca și codul Shore cu 9 qubit-uri, codul Steane poate corecta o eroare arbitrară
pe un qubit; deci iată cum funcționează: consideră că acest cerc reprezintă toate posibilele operații Pauli
care rezultă în sindromul tuturor plus unu, care este sindromul ce sugerează că nu au apărut erori
și că nimic nu este în neregulă; printre aceste operații avem elemente ale stabilizatorului, sau mai exact
operații care sunt proporționale cu elemente ale stabilizatorului, și avem de asemenea erori netriviale care schimbă spațiul codului cumva, dar nu sunt
detectate de cod; și știm prin definiția distanței că fiecare operație Pauli din această categorie trebuie să aibă ponderea cel puțin
D, deoarece D este definit ca ponderea minimă a acestor operații; avem de asemenea operații Pauli
care cauzează apariția altor sindroame, și am putea considera fiecare sindrom pe rând dacă dorim, dar aici ne imaginăm
că a apărut un astfel de sindrom S; acum imaginează-ți că E este o eroare în această
categorie care are ponderea strict mai mică decât jumătate din distanța D; ei bine, nu știm că aceasta este
neapărat operația cu pondere minimă din acest cerc; deci să luăm C ca operația cu pondere minimă din această mulțime, sau una dintre ele în caz de egalitate
deci ar putea fi că C este egal cu E sau posibil nu; dar deoarece C are
pondere minimă, știm că nu poate avea pondere mai mare decât ponderea lui E, deoarece C este de asemenea în mulțime
și are pondere minimă; deci operația de corecție C trebuie să aibă pondere strict mai mică decât jumătate din
D; deci ce se întâmplă dacă aplicăm această corecție C la orice devine starea noastră după ce eroarea E
apare? Răspunsul este că starea pe care o obținem este C înmulțit cu E aplicat codificării originale, deoarece mai întâi
înmulțim cu E (aceea a fost eroarea) și apoi înmulțim cu C pentru a încerca să o corectăm; și acest produs trebuie să fie în
stabilizator sau proporțional cu un element al stabilizatorului, și iată de ce: în primul rând, deoarece E și C ne dau același sindrom,
WEBVTT
C înmulțit cu E trebuie să ne dea sindromul tuturor plus unu; asta deoarece pentru un
generator stabilizator dat, fie C și E comutează ambele cu acel generator, fie amândoi anticomutează; trebuie să fie la fel pentru
ambii, deoarece sindroamele sunt aceleași; și dacă te gândești la asta pentru un moment, implică că C înmulțit cu E trebuie
să comute cu toți generatorii stabilizatori; și în final, C înmulțit cu E trebuie să fie
în stabilizator, deoarece ponderea sa nu poate fi mai mare decât suma ponderilor lui C și E; deci ponderea sa
este strict mai mică decât D; și aceasta înseamnă că corectăm cu succes E, deoarece aplicarea lui E urmată de C nu face nimic
spațiului codului; deci asta este grozav, dar există o singură problemă: pentru codurile stabilizatoare
în general, calcularea operației cu ponderea cea mai mică care cauzează un sindrom dat este o problemă dificilă din punct de vedere computațional
și într-adevăr asta este adevărat chiar și pentru codurile clasice, pe care în acest context le putem gândi ca coduri stabilizatoare
unde apar doar matrice identitate și matrice Pauli Z ca factori tensoriali în stabilizator
generatori; deci spre deosebire de pasul de codificare, operațiile Clifford nu ne vin în ajutor de data aceasta; și singura soluție rezonabilă este
să alegem coduri specifice pentru care corecțiile bune pot fi calculate eficient; și nu există nicio rețetă pentru
aceasta; pur și simplu, conceperea codurilor stabilizatoare de acest tip face parte din Arta
designului codurilor cuantice; și acesta este un loc bun pentru a ne opri în această lecție; sper că te vei alătura mie
designului codurilor cuantice; și acesta este un loc bun pentru a opri; sper că te vei alătura mie
pentru lecția următoare, în care vom arunca o privire la câteva construcții specifice de coduri cuantice, inclusiv coduri care ilustrează Arta codurilor cuantice
într-un mod destul de spectaculos; la revedere pentru acum